whether you love it hate it or never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban it presenting the nanny of
the month runners-up Mount Dora Florida
where dog tethering is now forbidden
even on your own property in Texas state
Rep Bill zedler who wants to force
strippers to get state permits zedler
hopes the extra hassle will prompt
exotic dancers to find other types of
work but hey check out the bill cooked
up by our nanny of the month this bill
passes anyone smoking a cigarette or
using any type of nicotine without a
prescription could face more than 60
$200 fine or up to a year in prison
Oregon's state rep mid screen like this
author of the lock up the smokers bill
and he's also worried about the high
cost of incarceration we need to look at
sentencing reform we need to find a more
rational way to decide who gets in
prison not sure how expanding the drug
war is a rational way to reform prisons
but hey this guy's sold I hope it passes
and I hope people actually think about
it you know there's less and less
smokers every day anyway because they
know how bad it's warm check back next
month for more examples of busybodies
minding your own business